قتل تسعه من عناصر الامن واصيب خمسه او
خمسه عشر اخرون في انفجار بمنطقه سيبي
باقليم بلوشستان جنوب غربيه باكستان وقالت
الشرطه ان الهجوم ناجم عن تفجير الانتحاري
بينما قالت مصادر محليه ان الحادثه وقع
جراء في جاري عبوه الناسفه اثناء مرور
دوريه لقوات الامن في المنطقه
سمير النمر مراسل الجزيره ينضم الي من
اسلام اباد مرحبا سمير التطورات الابرز
والمعلومات المتوفره حتى اللحظه
نعم الانفجار حدث صباح اليوم واستهدف
سياره كانت سياره نقل كانت تقل عدد من
الجنود العيدون من مهمه امنيه وهذا
الحادثه وقع في طريق في منطقه السيبي في
اقليم بوليس وقتل فيه بحسب بيان من الشرطه
ومعلومات ومصادر محليه في المنطقه ادى الى
مقتل تسعه من افراد قوات الامن واصابه نحو
خمسه عشر
كان وزير الداخليه الباكستاني قد مدد في
هذا الحادث واعز اسر القتلى واتمنى الشفاء
للجرحى كما انه طالب باجراء تحقيق لكنه لم
يسمي الجهه التي تقف وراء هذا الحدث مصادر
محليه في المنطقه اكدت لنا ان انفجار
قنبله قنبله زرعت في الشارع اثناء عوده
هؤلاء الجنود من تامين مهمه امنيه لفعاليه
ثقافيه في منطقه اخرى كان هؤلاء الجنود
وهذا الشيء اللافت يرتدون زي مدنيا بغرض
التمويه ولكن يبدو ان الجهه التي
استهدفتهم كانت تراقبهم بشكل مكثف بشكل
متسارع في تلك المنطقه او على العموم
اقليم بروجستان دائما
متوترا للغايه من جانب امني حيث تشهد
المنطقه عده حوادث امنيه كان اخرها
استهداف ايضا
سرعه دراجه ناريه الاسبوع الماضي وادى الى
مقتل اربعه من جنود الامن في تلك المنطقه
سنتابع معركه التطورات في سياق مواعيدنا
الاخباريه المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك سمير
النمري كنت معي من اسلام اباد